[Musique]
qui
il est sympathique joue les noms je
kiffe ce mec moi c'est vrai il est
différent et franchement il a un vrai
talent j'étouffe l'élégance des frets à
l'ombre sans rigoler au moins qui
sortent un peu tu vois john eales un
style non mais sans déconner de giuly
n'a même pas les mecs moi qui l'aï
d'avril un vrai délire il a une voix
différente et une otite et vocale très
très forte
il est bon pour un truc c'est du 12 non
mais c'est vrai alors les chéris vous
continuez à nous laisser des messages
alors je vous le dis pour nous laisser
des messages et pour qu'on vous appelle
il ya olivier habib le producteur
d'émissions qui va me le redire dans
l'oreillette c'est très simple c'est
libre antenne baba at gmail.com vous
laisser vous laissez votre numéro libre
antenne baba à gmail point com vous
laissez votre numéro de téléphone
et on peut vous appeler à tout moment
pour discuter avec vous d'ailleurs on
aura dix mis en ligne dans un instant
pour le moment il y a notre ami claude
alexis notre voyant qui est là mais
juste avant qu on a tous une question à
poser aux voies dont un ce soir voilà
franchement on a envie matthieu
delormeau a demandé s'il allait trouver
l'amour en 2017
il va nous dire dans un instant vous
aurez chacun une question il ya des amis
qui sont passés nous voir d'autres amis
que j'aime beaucoup il ya un garçon
voilà s est elle est aussi ça c'est un
comédien nous et il sortait et il était
qui est une amie voilà ils sont venus
nous voir une amie voilà qu'on connaît
bien puisque elle travaille d'ailleurs
avec vous puisqu'elle fait dans pense
quoi camille et vous êtes un petit peu
bah oui bon bah oui 17 à me masser
chambre noire des toons alors s'en va je
sais jamais son nom de famille parce
qu'elles changent tout le temps mais moi
ce sera mon moi c'est sandra la
sympathique csls comme on l'appelle
thomert 6 les cendres avaient donc on
est venu avec sa femme
les rhodaniens commun
merci frérot des framboises des frais
vous êtes vous êtes inquiet tant qu'il
ya de la sauce y a de la chance les
chéris bien virginie au maine ou de la
sauce ma chérie vous étiez réellement
dans le quartier vous allez olla soit
c'est quand même assez ça la sauce quoi
en fait faut la voir les choses comme ça
c'est du lourd est au maire si cela est
grande écoute
alors ouais vous êtes en étant alors
j'avais appris qu'on le dos au départ en
fait
en fait vous êtes ensemble de ouf quoi
ah ouais ouais ouais ouais tiens
commission parce que j'avais des données
de l'ensemble c'est rien du tout me
semble au fond mais on savait ce que
j'aime j'ai quand même des paparazzi en
ce moment qui conviait j'allais chez
aller chercher tout ça et l'on arrive
dans une émission
il est 3h20 du matin à base de main dans
la main francky quoi on est là on
effraie j'adore et je voudrais dire
thomert je le connais depuis des années
lui aussi c'est une merveille des
merveilles depuis des années soit
sérénade en coiffure c'est vrai c'est
quoi il aimait qu'il ya 17 ans non
prémat larguer des raisons qui lui sont
propres
non c'est vrai on va aller on s'est
retrouvé quand il a dégagé comme popopop
attention à ce que tu as laissé
attention on est en direct on passe à
l'antenne c'est que t'as pas encore
vraiment l'habitude de faire attention
et ne chauffe pas trop parce que je peux
balancer des dossiers non mais là je
vous sens joue sans frais vous vous êtes
renoue en vacances je vous ai vu des
photos de voir à quoi tu penses vraiment
que tu bosses
même plus la tête le gâchis quand il fit
graver leur nom mais je suis hyper
content de voir ensemble parce que je
vous adore les 2 1 mais c'est vrai est
au maire c'est un garçon d'une
gentillesse nan mais sans déconner c'est
un garçon et poids le lâche pas suis là
bas que lui un vrai gars mais je vais là
c'est un gars y est comme ça tu vois des
gars droit et la très peur à mussig
non mais toi tu est hyper fidèles sans
déconner quand t'es qu'un mec alors à
lyon pour vous dire elle sur la tête de
ma mère et demain il peut avoir brattle
ou ce qu'ils appellent ou brad pitt
bayal a plus de chance ce soit brad
pelous il est plus sur la région
parisienne
et bah rien bon en plus est c'est dur de
trouver mieux que il est bon maillage
les jambes allongées la beauté niveau
pour les temps pâtissent non mais c'est
vrai que la nuit lettre ouverte au maire
si ce n'est sans déconner c'est le blond
de gad elmaleh sur qui les bras c'est le
gars c'est la perfection mais il reste
bras et voilà il est sain mais sans
déconner il a cessé un truc dont il sait
tout faire l'hélicoptère al de conduite
ouais bien sûr oui je sais qu'il sait
faire les deux bras non ce n'est pas
qu'à la conduite ans et vous monsieur
vous vous êtes qui en fait voilà on est
on est on a compris que non mais c'est
mon père me voie rapide et la mairie
alors mais sans déconner tu seras
boillon est normal il m'a dit des trucs
de ouf horse crise était le père de deux
cadres ils ressemblent en douce hélas
hélas
et non vous c'est pas pareil c'est pas
lui qui est le coeur et un de très beaux
atouts je me suis alexis alors on en une
question de mathieu d'or vous connaissez
mathieu oui monsieur évidemment suis de
très près voilà vous l'aimez john
mathieu est valide
c'est la meilleure balle barcelone alors
juste claude et vous après une question
mathieu parce que ça fait longtemps
qu'ils cherchent qu'à moi c'est vrai que
maintenant que t'as pas une histoire
sérieuse toit deux ans ouais je sentais
des quines dernier connu n'ont pas connu
on s'appelait hugo il est 4 heures du
matin coleen bow hugo
il ya des mof qui s'appelle hugo l on
nous la personne la personne était à
deux ans bref c'est vrai et donc est
donc depuis rien de sérieux
non j'ai un peu regretter ça j'ai un peu
merdé voilà depuis rien c'est vous qui
l'avez base et ouais alors claude est ce
qu'il va trouver l'amour et dec ou pas
du tout qu'on met à regretter raboussa
alors alors de niveau 7 cartons cette
carte ça il faut qu'ils proches assurant
cette carte mathieu mon chéri tu vas
trouver l'amour parce que tu le mérites
mouche à la main gauche souhaite à mes
continuer les cherry à réagir sur
twitter je sais que vous êtes très
nombreux à nous alors s'ils donnent
vraiment des à moi les petits alba a
laissé ses plumes fawcett
non il va c'est bon alors alors pourtant
alors il y avait reconnu qu'à ses cartes
arms et des cartes celle où je sais pas
avec quoi ils jouent mais il est très
fort il m'a dit ah bon il m'a dit il m'a
dit que j'allais virer des gens alors ça
sent pas bon dos d'un effectif où je te
sens pas la ccid 2010 est entré
castellane et bénéfique pour lui sur le
plan sentimental
non c'est quelque chose qui se décide à
partir du printemps n'ont pu t'en as
maintiendrait en mars avril
c'est le petit dilemme c'est que cette
personne se trouvait à l'extérieur c'est
pas quelqu'un qui se trouve sur la
région parisienne chez alex attention
connu en anglais là oui c'est comme une
émission très libre alors là non c'est
vrai c'est vrai mais ça veut dire servir
paris joue pas ça peut être dans une
ville proche de paris sur notre pays non
c'est une ville qui est
quitte à l'extérieur pour moi s'est
passé ça en france en a les crocs il va
trouver quelqu'un qua non c'est
important il ne connaît pas encore que
je connais pas encore le cas les banques
en mars à partir du moins demain une
personne et provinciales je ne sont pas
remis en décembre comparé au spi on
déchante normalement avec quoi parti qui
qualifie ces mars les pistes de ski sur
ouï dire qu en fait vous j'ai remarqué
vous êtes encore plus relou la nuit un
truc de ouf alors posé chacun une
question bateau mère et est alors moi je
voudrais savoir moi est ce que un jour
je vais rencontrer le grand amour
[Rires]
la thématique sa mère sur ses genoux
non bien sûr il a déjà rencontré jaune
bien non claude dit lula méritait ce que
tu sois que ça va durer des douilles
non mais ça fait combien de temps que
vous êtes ensemble ça fait 17 ans mais
non ces six mois six mois c'est de lui
dont tu me parler quand tu m'as dit
geremek mais je peux pas te dire qu'il
sait c'est au maire responsable je le
connaissais son paletot monopolaire
monde en mal mais surtout tout le monde
le collège ne sort pas non plus un
moteur v ce que là je suis pas bien bon
alors tu vas à leur rencontre et ça veut
dire que c'est pas mal à répondre à ces
d'une bonne on fait un tollé
c'est la question du vih est ce qu'ils
vont avoir un enfant sans danser sur
j'en suis sur le fond mais je suis en
voyant ce nom mais alors est ce que
claude est ce qu'ils vont avoir un
enfant ensemble
et si oui ou non cet enfant va taper à
leur porte et ce qui sera normal qu est
ce qu avait si oui ou non le roux les
enfants attendent les enfants sont bourg
non mais je vous le dis voilà normal
enfin avec vous y voilà ils tracent
sympathique il sera sympathique quoi
même où il sera voilà il sera alors
claude claude turcotte les cartes le
frère maintenant je renie pas
d'écartement tous les cas rien à venir
quelqu'un même plutôt radieux pour vous
doyon puisqu'il ya également des projets
de déménagement
ok mais d'agir est pas contraint ces
déménagements il ya des travaux qui se
font au niveau de cette habitation
mais pas dans ce lieu vous ne resterez
pas très longtemps oui moi faire ya des
remous chez nous notamment j'ai fermé ma
gueule je t'écoute et je regardais pas
georges table est maintenant bien
[Musique]
d'accord vous si on vous dit tout aussi
cette fille drôle il ya des trucs je
peux pas nous inventer d'accord bon
alors pour moi y est donc marqué on n'a
tiré aucune car j'ai pas que tu entends
pas mais je le garde et un truc qui ne
tient jamais ratant deux minutes frère
je comprends rien au niveau
professionnel
autre temps entre-temps niveau
professionnel qui ressort par rapport à
des tournages qui doivent se faire et
mais ce sera peut-être un contretemps de
la rivière gaulle à devenir juge de paix
était désengagement dit c'est dans mes
cordes
allez ça va un retard d'un mois avec
deux tracés non elle lui parle comme ça
longtemps même pas ce qu'il dit non
alors les cherry on a ils ont posé
caudan tout cas c'est le seul qui bosse
toujours
ouais c'est vrai dans musique estime
inès 88 ans à nîmes il ya et il y à
dounia toujours monsieur pichon qui
[ __ ] et on embrasse non mais sans
déconner il est toujours en train de
regarder
il a crevé 14h et les pédales il veut
battre un record
il s'échauffe et c'est d'y aller vas-y
tu sais quoi je suis de l'histoire et il
est exceptionnel a franchement le record
là encore c'est quoi c'est combien comme
je dois faire pour battre le record mais
il doit faire mille kilomètres la vie
prend des sushis mon cas je me savais
que tu étais passé au chocolat dont je
me permets pas si on à isla doumbia au
téléphone qui nous appellent notre
classe à lui ça ça nuit sa traduction
commentant la monf euros ça va et en
forme tu dors pas encore fait il est
3h30 mais pourquoi me jeu content de
t'avoir les frais on ne pouvait pas être
là parce que je suis en pectacle à arras
et je voulais absolument que tu sois là
tu sais qu'on t'aime à mon chéri je te
kiffe est franchement franchement là les
gars qui sont autour de toi t elle ses
actifs
pourrais tu as vu il ya du monde quand
les gars ça y'a que des galets
maintenant tu y vas et même 5 mai pipita
caro est son maire ça fait trop plaisir
de voir voyage
merci merci ca est longtemps que j'ai
pas vu ouais tabaculteurs pompe
[Rires]
[Musique]
on est où et ça avec les meufs héros
parce que issa un chineur d'ouf arrêts
[Applaudissements]
le voyant d'hier soir a tiny gamecube ou
reims notre jeu de tri mais claude wade
jamais je veux avoir un gosse à claude
quant à ceux qui bavent à gauche et fo
sa date de naissance nom la surprise en
baisse alors sonné le prénom la date de
naissance mais ne devrait prénom son
prénom ces histoires ça ne devrait pas
vrai prénom sage à clermont merde j'ai
pas dit ça n'est pas pareil quand même
c'est le nîmois gaza mais c'est sûr
c'est un artiste et d'avoir violé dix
mois par exemple
tout le monde va pas tirer lauda est en
fait je m'appelle jean pierre foucault
[Rires]
c'est quoi ta d'apple sarba c'est quoi
ta date de naissance 1982 le dieu
fondèrent le 10 juin 1982 6
ouais du club le 6 ou le disent les
signes de sa 10e donc odyssée alors
claude et sa compagne quelques dettes
des naissances de sa confrère mais pas
comment ce que vous avez l'intention de
faire alors y'a pas de mal il n'a pas
nommé mais déjà un enfant toutes parts
merci alors n'attendez et léché se
concentrait claude la lega c'est
important c'est un ami capelle - devrait
il devrait déjà y en avoir un don quand
chez lui il devrait déjà y avoir un
enfant chez aussi alors et ça apparaît
enfin je dors tu l'as pas vu tu fais le
tour des maisons dans une n'hésite pas
ce que je n'ai pas dit alors je dis tu
devrait déjà avoir un enfant chez lui
mais pourquoi les voilà un enfant comme
shining qui fait peur non non il y a
étienne accident ou merde non mais on va
contacter claude à et elle a fait des
très belles collections et de la moelle
et c'est l'amour mars les niveaux avec
de nouveaux effectifs ils se
construisent sur une puce 2018 pour les
40 ans de battre héros en 2018 est
normalement normalement tu aurais 2018
voilà d'accord et tu viens nous voir
continuer ma tournée c'est qu'en 2018
d'accord on ferait rouge que faim énorme
bisou tu n'as bank contador astana et
mathieu beau gosse merci ça on t'aime
nammi is art ou te kiffe trop tu nous
manques fréron opus et oui tu reviens
quand tu veux voilà on est était ici et
claude jour est reversé coûte parce
qu'ils bossent de ouf
non franchement claude vraiment mais
ouais alors elle a un micro à la
microsoft sont évidents de se concentrer
sur une commande du bruit autour de
cette fatigue quand même un peu non ça
va aller chéri on à jimmy 1-1
téléspectateurs 14 skype qui est avec
nous jimmy oui oui oui vous entendez au
salut jimmy comment ça va pas ça on a
souffert on peut voir la personne
au sam adjibi ça va super oui alors
jimmy sais quoi je connais pas ton
métier mais je suis assistant manager
chez domino's j'adore ça nous connaît
les gars ça fait on m'a dit en rugby il
ya une heure on pendant une minute
y'a pas de soucis de pizzas donc
domino's pizza et pizza hut et et pizzas
sur la [ __ ] pizza rherrabi toi et pizzas
rachid à côté de chez moi
très bonne on ne croise rachid donc vous
série dont quoi pourquoi tu nous
appelles on est très content de t'avoir
déjà tu tues tu fais quoi dans la vie
je gère mes de l'est pas c'est pas chez
domino's pizza points exactement
patrick est le métier de clown danon
beaucoup s'est pas livré des pizzas
m'ont assez mangé là c'est toi quand tu
feras tu es 35 heures ce qui fera dire
tu vois tu mange des fruits tu fermes ta
gueule de masse à cette phrase de masse
et demain ça c'est qu'un appel à
l'article l'humiliation
jimmy eu mon chéri qu'es-tu belle dans
la vie qui va être question et dit moi
et toi revanche n'a pas l'habitude de
manger à mes bons frères attend ses
baguettes sont durs et qui va jouer de
la flûte de cannor mes coups j'ai su
bien non mais t'es bien je suis content
que tu sois la djibi m me fous pas non
célibataires chaque élargi de 19 ans 19
ans un d'innovation la vie jimmy mon
chéri tu as d'après comment ça se fait
que tu dors pas encore je n'avais pas de
manger chez les pizzas non mais en fait
on m'a dit oui
ne t'inquiète pas vers une heure on
croit à l'antenne des prêts à venir
j'étais entrain vente en faire l'héroïne
à nous aussi nous autres ça franchement
super elle a d'abord réagi me le fait
que la vérité
jamais je te trouve mignon alors moi je
ne mange pas de ce pain-là a franchement
non moi je vais maintenant ils me crois
que mathieu était un peu converti non
non non non non non je respecte bien
entendu je respecte et je suis pour un
que tout le monde soit voilà ouvert à
toute proposition
mais moi malheureusement je suis encore
fermés jusqu'à nouvel ordre
voilà je te le dis et vous serez les
premiers au courant bien entendu ainsi
on ré ouvre pour une liquidation totale
non ma chérie tu nous appelles pourquoi
en fait mais non juste je voulais
raconter une petite anecdote petite
anecdote
mais livreur chez un client sap abap ya
déjà une meuf qui est sorti avec un
livreur qui a craqué sur un livreur
autour des tables ou bien non mais c'est
quoi ces gens ces genres quoi tu rigoles
ml sans déconner c'est pas possible il
ya pas mal aimés gabonais en tout cas
elles ont gardé surmontera flamants
roses
dieu bénisse les gens m'appellent
bientôt quatre ans ce qui t'appelle pour
4 heures du matin deux vagues osbourne
kelly slater tindara dans le queyras et
les gens capables sur alimentaire de la
basse et moi en fait que je suis con
j'ai dit oui votre chéri e
ouais juste tant d où toi sorti
vocalement a toujours célibataire alors
qu'il cherche quoi mais par contre ce
que je peux te dire c'est qu'il ya un de
mes livres à ancien livreur ouais y'a
choper beaucoup de clientes n'ont comme
quoi il arrivait pour livrer il y livrer
des piliers choper le numéro gens rire
envoyé un texto direct mais genre juste
je vous trouve très jolie est
généralement le lendemain à trouver
n'ont jamais compris comment
ah ouais c'est arrivé un truc comme ça
s'est passé pendant l'été au studio est
souvent moi je commande souvent là-bas
parce que je bouge tout le temps quand
je vois cette fois par jour c'est ma
passion et je commence à les lire arrive
et quand ils arrivent devant ils me
reconnaît sauf qu'ils ont une brocante a
appelé monsieur réprimant voir mr hulot
vous y voilà ouais frais et toi cap a
répondu non non mais elle est sans
déconner je peux ouvrir son mec c'est
pas il peut dormir mais j'ai une
question justement pas répondre avec toi
c'est un truc de ouf
toi tu es comme ça aussi ouais mais tu
sais pas il peut dormir et mon frère il
dort décrié leader beaucoup d'allées mon
frère tu es tu dors il peut dormir mon
frère et lui laissait rien n'est sérieux
ton mec aussi un ouais j'espère je
connais pas mais je le sens au pif
au pire il y à la maison tous les soirs
bah oui mais à la maison quand tu es
prêt je vais je vais te dire sinon c'est
pas que je balaye deux parties sont non
mais c'est vrai quand ils se déplacent
ensemble ils sont beaucoup ensemble
c'est la clé mois sur l'autre
excusez-moi batman il peut arrêter là
alors prix mimos humaine est ce que tu
as à nous laisser voilà voilà
non mais j'en fais de gros bisous c'est
vraiment un amour est happé le message
est oui je te crois où tu viens nous
voir quand tu comme on chez reed avec
apple et b avec plaisir n'y a pas de
souci dans les zones à très bientôt 28
et traitent très mignon il est beau
gosse il a quelque chose à dire et il a
quelque chose s'est désolé là quelque
chose et moi je connais là je connais la
beauté jeter visagiste je connais la
beauté à on a une jeune fille en ligne
elle s'appelle alors comment comment
s'appelle la jeune fille qui en ligne
aux new rose noir c'est sûr que ça ouais
non illzach 34 ans aux nouveaux aloses
nour aux nour
apparemment on a des problèmes de
liaison 1 vous avez fait le numéro aux
régies d'accord oui oui et c'est normal
qu'on a pas la personne d'accord la
personne à raccrocher pour des raisons
qui lui incombe en principe c'est quoi
est-il des attaques par skype pour
tracer dollars d'autres jouaient les lie
au genou royal d'ur salut aux nous nous
rendons kadorama un nom de traiteur
libanais à moi je vois bien les gars
qu'il faut je vois bien les gars ils
sont chez eux le soir les gars nous
commandent choses devront s en écho net
a fait d'autres c'est plutôt qu'on va
pas manger là bas onze jours que tu as
quel âge ma chérie tu as quel âge il
nous est dit 19 34 qu'est ce tu dis toi
combien parce qu'un mais ces pauses
nours plusieurs à ses poses l'ours et
mina en fait qu'on en ligne ah oui nina
petit ami senna la mc nina que je
connais vérité là que tu connais
commencèrent à mâcher real et alors elle
c'est aussi ça c'est c'est une vision et
une fille formidable qui vient très
souvent nous voir dans tu sois en poste
qui twitte beaucoup et qui fait partie
de ma chérie et qui me laisse beaucoup
de mp voilà je voudrais vous laisse des
messages tous les jours pratiquement
haut à 4 à 5 et 5 0 mois d'âge et c'est
pas très cool que l'état ferme à sale
malatier massif devant tout le monde des
couleurs
mais je peux pas répondre à tous les
messages que l'on se fait plus rien mais
quel âge et l'animal
elle a attaqué la jeune hina déjà 23 24
tam a pas de vainqueur non tirées pour
eux mais on dirait que j'ai fait une
erreur mais moi je te retrouves ta
maintenant tamek n'innove pas parce
qu'elle est très très mignonnes ni là
attention à la scie mais l'envoie non
pas quoi merci maintenant totalement
pourquoi t'as pas de mec qui te fais
tous mes mails à 21 ans elle est super
mignonne vous dire qu'il nous fait une
belle jambe
non mais franchement tu étais déjà
sortir qu'avec ou pas pas encore joué
comme un mec bon lorsqu'on à 3 2 par 2 2
à toi tu sais pas sur quoi encore vous
voulez qu'est ce que tu dis non
messieurs jo j'ai rien dit j'ai deux ou
trois pas l'air très sûr c'est passé t2
c'était le 2 nina pourquoi la famille
pour nous après tu aimes bien mathieu
c'est papa il est un pari qu'il a pris
beaucoup trop de plein fouet dans
l'émission du détroit
c'est génial match mais s'est expliqué
les ailes et elle est très proche et
très amoureux de cyril pas du tout
répond le cyril est légèrement
[Musique]
nina li na n'est là pourquoi il tenait
pourquoi il est trop présent dites nous
pourquoi
mais là j'aime bien c'est juste que je
trouve qu'il a pris beaucoup de place
alors comment ce que j'aimais bien la
limite on s'est quand même le côté un
peu plus bas des inconnus jetés par des
parts à beltsville verdade tout en
guidant cousus ensemble et trouvent
parce qu'ils tomberont way amène à dire
que tu vas découvrir via damien qui va
qu'il va bien et qu'il a et puis on a
d'autres cherchant à nick mallet
géraldine maillet tu le connaissais pas
ah non non mais moi j aime bien
et ben voilà ah oui l'une des raisons
qui m'a appelé il ya deux ans et qui m'a
dit qu'elle était très énervé call girl
mallet et voilà ah oui oui parce qu'elle
avait dit ouais ouais elle avait dit à
la télé réalité
et sinon ma chérie tu seras tu m'aimes
bien toujours wet avatar moyens demain
et si j'ai d'un hiver c'était trop drôle
parce qu'en gros il porte les heures
tout âge ou non et du côlon dagbert et
voit que changer des charmes attentes
téléphone il me fait que je suis tu
attends bref je vais m en haut-parleur
suffisent ensuite on va dépasser le mois
passé voilà comment savoir c'est qui
quand tu t'appelles serait vraiment très
robert sabbah y toi
écoute moi si ça va écoute depuis 6
heures du matin je suis réveillé mon
frère c'est vrai d'une mito nom et
habite à côté je suis un pont de cinq
voix et moi je te fais un qui sait qu'il
a besoin d'un hiver tu peux demander à
matthieu delormeau
ouais je file photo avec lui aller sur
ton twitter nord là jusqu'à 4h suite aux
chauffeurs blesse
je l'adorent comment tu t'appelles quand
j'étais plus jeune comment tu t'appelles
dakar - oui mais comment et pour qu'ils
allaient monopoliser la parole
comment il s'appelle lennon michael à
adrian d'accord arménien alors une série
de dix minutes l'embase site avait vent
mais la vraie ressource pas dit si
j'aurais aimé vous je ne bouge pas d'ici
là je suis la burqa mais ils bougent pas
qui sait manier paroisse pas d'accord et
tu regrettes tu rentres où toi ce que tu
rentres du duster si la wii 4 heures du
matin des cépages cépages utilisés mais
j'étais à ton prêt n'était pas non
lesquels psa bauer elle m'a fait un
cadeau
ouf pour mon anniversaire elle m'a elle
m'a fait un bond birth avec sa copine
qui est formidable également avec marc
hé bah bah ouais les allées super
mignonne aussi ça a d'abord allé
beaucoup plus jeune que toi les rangs
ouais je sais c'est un amour elle ça va
être une bombe atomique au sien comme
toi bon bah ma chérie merci nous avons
rappelé rentre bien là mais avec mercy
way et loris calvache je n'aime pas il
faut arrêter de tout prendre
personnellement ils doivent avoir des
divergences à personne mais tendance à
dire capables en femme qu'il adore et
tout et tout le monde trouve ça
important vente était alité nous revoilà
compiègne ben voila merci minarets merci
ni la schtroumpf acrobates cheryl et m'a
dit eh bien elle est très belle et bien
nous voir vite je t'embrasse fort bouche
un coin tranquille revient tellement
après l'arbre sébastien loeb a très bien
que dans moins de forme quoi les
couteaux très fatigué je les tue paul
aime à dire parce que ce n'est qu'avec
moi demain après midi va dormir un peu
frérot va dormir un peu lâche se voit
allez merci toad alexis qui est
[Applaudissements]
merci vous y allez les cherry et free
n'ont l'appui des filons et fracasse la
bise ou chérie merci et on attend le
prochain album donc on a dit quoi et
comment
comment ça va s'appeler normalement ça
les dérange c'est que ça les dérange
[Musique]
alors les chérifien gdg martial qui me
dira qu'ils me qui pose une question
martial qui nous regardent martial
marseillais qui était sur nrj martial
contre moi je la donne aux garçons ils
adorent c'est un amour le garçon à ma
mère il voulait demander aux voyants
s'il allait retrouver du travail
il sut au talent lui c'est sûr et
certain je peux venir lui bien sûr très
très grosse star je vous dis dans quatre
cinq ans pourrait bien sûr mais c'est
sûr jean-michel il a un très gros talent
il passe bien content and et lumineux et
l'amiral très bon alors mais jerry et je
veux remercier quand même thomert d'être
avec nous avec sandra je l'adoré c'est
un amour aussi la designer de des
conneries il avec admis un orient pour
ce coin calme maintenant
edmond elle est super ça les premiers
héros thomert et 10 mois sans égal et
toi tu es tu tombes des films de ouf
quand même franchement ils tournent pas
les films que tout le monde aimerait
tourner aussi parce qu'en plus il a eu
la corpulence il est musclé à bord son
âge mais j'aurais adoré être musclé
comme conneries parce qu on a beaucoup
d'écart mais quand même à son âge était
déjà pas baraque comme ça que ça l'ofcom
et akena 54 50 klm a fait pas mais j'ai
jamais été balèze
c'est à l'époque ça se faisait pas de
rappeler que la salle à bord du tout un
beau corps et tu fais pas cinquante
quatre mois je t'aurais donné 50 ans et
demi mac cette fois-là la bia quoi comme
projet la thomert moi j'écoute je viens
de finir là
hier le montage d'une séquence que j'ai
réalisé moi d'être d'un film et je suis
en écriture je finis je finis un
scénario tu vas faire ton film sur quoi
c'est une histoire d'amour sur fond de
polar basé sur une histoire vraie écoute
c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr j'ai joué
j'ai tourné une séquence juste pour
montrer quoi ça va ressembler et on m'a
demandé de jouer dedans je les fais
c'est pas évident je voudrais tu es
devant et derrière
merci madame j'ai vu j'ai vu thomas la
première fois qu'est vraiment excellent
il faisait la première partie de djamel
exact longtemps il était son one man
était très très drôle
incroyable je l'avais qu'il avait une
double origine jeu république s'était
déjà c'était le truc avec jacques baron
ce n'est pas ton le temple est l'endroit
où j'étais venu le voir au temple toi
aussi j'étais venu boire et when this
way toi tu étais parti avant la fin
parce que c'était vraiment de la merde à
l'étude ordures nous nous étonnons vous
étiez venu me voir oui bien sûr on
s'arrête au maire était venu voir
thomert c'est un vrai amour ne me sers
et le gars était venu me voir bientôt
mère se bonifier avec le temps quoi
pourquoi il faut ni sinon ya toujours
des mots et 10 ans et 1 mois je me
souviens surtout dans largo winch
voilà ma part c'est à ce moment là je
trouve que depuis ce moment-là c'est
c'est sans fin quoi ça s'arrête plus non
mais elle est l'hôte et cela me fait
plaisir c'est ma copine sandra vous
allait super bien ensemble moelleux je
me bonifie - mais gilles a un je m'en
fous de son physique moi mais c'est
important que je m'en fous de son
physique parce que je l'aï fait parce
que je regarde en premier chez lui mais
c'est un amour de bec
non mais c'est vrai que c'est un mec
droit voilà et ça me change des gens que
je serai content bonjour le feu je ne
dirais pas ça enfin je crois
je crois que j'ai jamais autant ri que
la fois on avait fait faux bond on a
fait fort boyard ensemble on est chez
quoi on a fait cette émission on est
retombé on était c'était une année où
les équipes dormait sur la glace et
c'est d'aller où on n'avait rien à faire
un peu tout
on va pas se mentir moi le gars quand il
m'a présenté et fait cirer on ne sait
pas trop ce qu'il fait il verra le gars
est là bon c'est pas pourquoi qua non
mais c'est vrai toi tu bosses est déjà
un peu mais moi on ne sait pas du tout
où j'étais on était mais on est on est
retombé et géant j'avais l'impression
d'être en colonie de vacances avec genre
11 en quoi un rappel on avait fait pipi
duo du fort on s'est baladé pendant la
nuit dans le fort il était vénère après
louvain c'est vrai on est rentré dans
toutes les salles ouest et tous les
pièges des pièges et vénère après new
wave et attrape la boule on n'a pas
dormi l'aller alors s'est passé un truc
particulier que vous dressez voir c'est
un truc très particulier que la boule
feu la boule voilà parce que on embrasse
sa famille il nous a quittés la moule
voilà et c'est vrai que j'ai fait un
truc à la boule tu étais là bas mais que
c'est moi qui ai lancé le truc tu as et
marca lancé truc tu veux vous dire dans
un instant parce que même à cette
heure-ci sur ses beats on arrive à
vendre encore de la pub mais il est
quand même 15h50 et on va se retrouver
dans un instant pour la suite des 35
heures de baba a tout de suite montré
beauté à tout de suite
[Musique]
en tout cas on est très heureux de vous
un compagnon de la champagne et voilà
comment ça voilà laisser les 35 heures
alors les cherry hill va être 4 heures
du matin ça fera donc ça fera donc 4
heures du matin 14 heures que je serai à
vos côtés donc à l'antenne donc en
direct et tu n'as toujours pas fait la
moitié toujours été la moiti nous reste
beaucoup beaucoup de temps quand même 1
n'a toujours pas fait petit gars fillon
et la cgtb talent à toi ya que ça qui
est intéressant est ce que moi j'ai une
vessie très petit
ah oui et du coup je sors à chaque fois
que l'occasion se présente
on n'a pas envie de voir grande à
bourges les petites baies site non mais
c'est alors 14000 euros pour
l'association c'est que du bonheur pour
l'instant il ya eu un dos énorme
juste avant qu'on vienne bien mathieu
d'embauché il ya quand même une blouse
voyons mais non mais c'est rien mais
c'est un amour de mecs et franchement il
est bon les chéris ce que je propose
c'est qu'on se fasse une petite petite
vingtaine de minutes d'action vérité
avec les personnes qui sont chez eux
voilà qu'on accompagne je sais qu'il y
en a plein qui arrive pas à dormir il a
peut-être qu'ils se réveillent tôt qui
vont bosser maintenant je pense à vous
les shérifs vous faites gros bisous et
il ya quand même un mec qui s'appelle
pascal pitch pascal pech qui est
d'ailleurs encore en train de pédaler le
garde la tête avec 14 heures qui
pédalent alors lui lui diront soirée va
être homologué ou pas parce que lui
c'est énorme ce qui fait joli et non pas
le record c'est qu'il va faire 35 heures
de vélo frein 35 heures de vélo il faut
bien il est propice à s'arrêter c'est
paraît-il garino bout du rouleau il faut
bien je vous le dis franchement j'ai pas
bien pascal slama frérot frère pascal ça
va au grand frère ah oui ça va un
parfait way pascal tu es sûr que tu veux
faire les 35 heures baba quoi c'est bien
parti pour
et puis sur celui qui est bien parti
pour partir il a fait telle kilomètres
des jeunes et ça fait combien de
kilomètres pascal oui à combien de
kilomètres dans quarante bornes j'aurais
fait 400 combien 400 morts ouais il a
fait le plus dur
rr et deauville il a fait
paris-deauville aller-retour way est un
vrai frein ouais pascal t mais si tu
veux arrêter arrête un thé sûreté en
forme encore ou pas non on va pas jouer
petit bras
pourquoi il fait baiser avec un scooter
il va arrêter mais moi j'adore j'adore
ce mec
pascal tu veux tu as mangé quelque chose
qui met ces bons qui roule sur la route
de 21 est ce que tu as mangé à manger
bon et la manche et non mais j'adore ce
mec tu me sens et c'est énorme ce qui
fait que nous on fait les zazous la 14
heures d'antenne céréales huiles a fait
14 heures de vélo à 40 km heure qu'on
n'ait rien demandé mais sur un gong ou
par non mais c'est vrai ou si vous
postez qui n'est pas payé en emeghara
même pour des artistes rester comme ça
que l'on fait là qui attendait pas des
artistes arrête on a rien à retisser
ville commerces un artiste ouais vous
n'aurez pas des artistes nous avons mené
quoi nous t'invitons tu te considères
comme côte comme un artiste
ouais bah oui comme un artiste doit bah
oui mais un artiste de coin ça bouge ça
j'ai pas encore mais ça va je vais
trouver quels types d'artistes bas on
n'est pas des artistes on est des
charlatans soutiens moi qui la vérité
alors tu as beaucoup de talent pour
mathieu mais pour moi animateurs
animateur c'est par un artiste tôt
martin lartigue franchement mais
pourquoi plus que nous à nancy pas
d'artiste c'est celui qui distribue du
bonheur bah dis pas de conneries un
talon un mec qui distribue du bonheur
c'est christophe maé
c'est quoi pour moi un artiste jean
michel baert
c'est quelqu'un qui crée gauche aux
manoeuvres une heure où l on crée rien
franchement thomert c'est un artiste
même un actif est un acteur six mois
anne une émission c'est un art assure
pas d'accord - l'armée de partir je nous
considère pas comme à l'arc la demi
heure 1
un art mineur ouais alors alors pourquoi
la bomba voilà les chéris on a des
cartes action vérité je propose qu'on
s'en fassent un petit jean michel vous
cochez une vérité ou une action je
choisis oui à des dockers ou par non non
mais derrière vérité alors être qu'elle
est qu'elle est je vais la lire merci
des trucs
ah oui quand même quelles choses
illicites as tu déjà consommé c'est con
que ça tombe sur soi ce n'est qu'après
mûre moi j'aurais pu ne pas mentir
j'aurais pu dire voilà rien mais là toi
il est l'ami 4h du matin j'ai pas envie
qu'on ait le csa sur le dos non j'ai
déjà fumé de la marijuana avec une
copine j'en étais très fan et qui essaie
de me pousse là dedans et eux les
fellini donc mais j'ai tant que j'ai
testé grogne n'est pas crédible sisters
inscrits 1 est le seul truc que tu as
peut-être fait des trucs mais après j'ai
oublié enfin j'aime bien tester des
choses
ouais mais non mais c'est bel et bien
pour moi j'aime être testé j'ai mis à
repousser les limites et j'aime bien un
peu ce qui est légal c'est vrai c'est un
petit côté rock'n'roll c'est que j'aime
pas trop les règles curseur et j'admets
un peu dépassée des trucs on a des bien
sûr sinon je vous rappelle la drogue
c'est pas bien c'est mal nous avons vu
c'est zéro mois pour l'achever
d'insurgés jamais pris et je suis bien
dans ma tête bien dans mon corps mais
c'est bien dans mon slip
c est important maintenant les excès
c'est peut-être la vitesse l'alcool
bref vous vous assurez les meufs le les
clubs libertins savez vous
vous avez déjà fait l'amour avec
beaucoup beaucoup de meuf ah oui le pire
quoi vous et combien de fric une
question j'ai fait avec plusieurs oui
avec des gens connus
vous serez pas des gens connus alors se
déplacent les mains fodé mcconnery
chanter dès l'es2 après l'opération
chanteuse actrice lana gratis actrice
bah oui forcément
actrice et elle est ce les femmes de
gens connus ou six noms des ballons
salon thème je l'avais dit aux fans de
foot
oui ouais et vous avez balancé j'avais
des joueurs du raf à d'un joueur du psg
là c'est bon c'est bon on l'a balancé
une fois mais je veux le carreau
problème cartes action vérité alors
donné ma chance est nul c'est boire un
verre d'eau salée il a très bien quoi ah
ouais quoi ah ouais il va l'inventer tu
vas à nantes et un tribun mais non ce
brevet sus et non un bonbon suis non
mais vous croyez quoi non mais oh
l'outil se sont tous est clair et comme
des oufs là sans déconner les gars tout
ce que vous devez sucéen voix de de la
façon la plus sensuelle possible devant
voilà devant cette caméra qu'est la main
d'accord oui attention vous avez loupé
grand crocodile a dit non prenez le
crocodile 6 6 3 le crocodile et ses
ministres à propos ni trop petit pour
ces minus qu'odile de crocodile si le
crocodile
je sais le petit crocodile l'essentiel
c'est ma tête c'est pas un crocodile
bombe à autre chose
mais alors quatre heures satan c'est à
dire des jeunes qui nous regarde a
acquis les lourds à l'écart ou avoir une
musique
mais non il n'y a rien ou un sensuel que
mettent les bords de la mersey rebellez
vous mettez le bisou de jul c'est sympa
pour le plaisir d'herbert léonard et est
maintenant de 6
[Musique]
la surprise comme quoi une quinzaine de
gares non mais franchement vous avez
joué le jeu car mathieu action vérité
allait si bien dans leur guerre si on
fait une petite virée cta et par quel
genre de choses ou quelque chose
regrettes-tu d'avoir fait dans ta vie tu
as un truc que tu retiens c'est bien
vrai ça va dire ce qu'est un truc que
j'apprécie bah oui un peu mireille du
mal de moi mais je les attends on adore
les trucs assez mal en egypte est
angoissant excusez moi ils vont gueuler
comme ça pendant deux heures encore
bahia qui sont il ya des sous et ben
c'est quoi c'est le cycliste adacore
vers l'enclos rien me dire tu sais quoi
ça ça va rejoindre le truc de jean-mi
tout à l'heure est déjà au bout du
rouleau mais quand j'étais au ps qui
peut parler un peu moins port et qui dit
en citant le pitch non mais je l'adoré
ce que leur dit qu'ils adorent le gars
alors quand j'étais au canada un soir
une nuit on est petit et jeune femme à
vos remarques 25 ans et à y avait il ya
des potes et tout ça et on avait décidé
un soir bêtement qu'on allait essayer
des champignons hallucinogènes n'ont pas
regretté faut prendre un petit peu à
peine genre 0,5 g un truc comme ça et on
s'est pris bolton jeunes a appris
beaucoup
non évidemment je prenais jamais ces
choses là et donc au bout de 2 du nom
n'est jamais ces conneries banon mais
jamais évidemment mais les gars m'a jeté
au canada j'ai 23 ans je peux me
paraîtrait 25 j'avais 22 ans bref on a
pris tout ça et ça s'est mal passé et on
a fait des espèces de bad trip dans tous
les sens c'était la nuit au canada et
moi je sentais très mal et je suis parti
dans la rue parce que j'étais
complètement j'ai perdu la map je suis
parti dans la rue me suis promené est
tout nu tellement je suis tombé quelque
part et je me suis réveillé à l'hôpital
où j'ai ou je
je me suis réveillé et il s'occupait de
moi et tout ça et nana j'avais fait je
sais pas quoi un bad trip total avec ce
truc là et on trouve à l'hôpital et est
franchement au moins tu sais quoi me
suis dit un truc c'est que ça m'a
dégoûté de tout ces trucs hallucinogènes
et c'est très bien ça m'a déchu de tout
ça on avait besoin de ça et et
franchement ça m'avait bien fait
paniquer messages éducatifs
sinon il ya une émission que vous
regardiez finir la personne qui regrette
d'avoir fait mouche c'était le meilleur
chien ce témoin était de reconnaître
qu'on s'est un peu loupé sur nrj 12 avec
ça avant il ya des gens qui sont là au
public un public qui êtes vous ou alors
touba benyamine donc de dailymotion
bonjour et qui la jeune fille à côté
vous des braves aujourd'hui bras c'est
qui cet amas bientôt si vous n'avez pas
compris mais la coquille c'est vous et
vous allez parler bien dans le micro
valait bien au micro vous êtes vous êtes
qu'il et bora bora
ok je suis une amie doc et benjamins de
thomas b connaît elle connaît non pas en
boîte par des amis en commun qu'ont et
vous allez le pechoux non c'est juste un
ami juste un ami vous êtes à 4h maurice
avec le thomas et vous n'avez pas sur
tout ce que j'avais compris d'être là le
noeud qui bougera pas là je vais vous
dire que thomas jauch le collège thomas
il a souvent plusieurs lièvres à la fois
trop cher tout de même et vous me
connaissez pas moi il est beau garçon
mais sinon tout est fait mais non
pourquoi parce que on est alors là il
aya thomas qui se dit [ __ ] j'ai tout
fait et on a fait si on a fait ça et là
frères hanouna bah voilà c'est terminé
c'est bon quoi pourra vous le confirmer
non ce serait vraiment se passera jamais
rien avec lui non mais vous êtes ami
depuis combien de temps on se connaît
depuis un bon moment
il a tenté quelque chose on n'est plus
amie depuis peu il a tenté quelque chose
ou pas est ce qu'il a tenté quelques
j'étais il ya eu vote il est le père daf
derrière tout rouge après que thomas van
hamme ils viennent de ces soirées thomas
juste prenez micro votre avis justement
est ce que tu voulais la pécho pas du
tout dit la vérité non dit la vérité l
acteur non dit la vérité
oui c'est vrai alors maintenant que tu
sais qu'ils voulaient de pécho est-ce
que tu as changé son fusil d'épaulé
micro touba franchement ça me fait
beaucoup
ouais merci thomas je vais réfléchir
sincérité moi m'ont dit les mouches ont
changé d'âne
oui oui oui où les moules ont changé de
rochers et vous vous allez rentrer chez
eux jusqu'au bout mais non mais on rêve
parce qu'on va alors donc ça c'est pas
possible on va y réfléchir mais bon
j'aime bien voilà faire un petit bisou
voulais pas faire un petit action vérité
pour le kiff
ben alors sortez prôné une action mais
je vais la prendre mathieu bersée
moncheaux du tarn amour ce que je suis
loin nous est chaud bouillant
vous êtes un peu ouais alors l'action là
les folles allait elle et elle tombe
bien pas déboutonne le pantalon de
quelqu'un juste avec la bouche alors bas
je crois qu'il a une fermeture éclair
c'est marc belzile enlève fermeture
éclair chez un jogging on peut pas faire
ça a donné
ou alors faut vraiment être consentant
de ouf quoique ont surtout bah voilà on
est ravis sur la bouche en brèche ouais
ouais c'est pas une bague à embrasse sur
la bouche quelqu'un de ce groupe qui est
sur la droite par zone embrasse sur la
bouche quelques heures de ce qui est un
gage copains c'est qu'on voit c'est pour
nom c'est pour vous c'est bon non je
passe jamais deux sans trois la dernière
page et des règles précises et des
huissiers qui tous les quarts d'heure et
à mettre ma chance un saphir la personne
alors on est allé si on avait le match
bien voulu fantômes qui me déçoit bouche
n'importe qui avec moi impliquant il se
passe jamais rien de plus à bisous
franchement je peux pas j'ai mes parents
qui peuvent regarder alors n'importe
quoi je suis mac mêmes faits à me fait
pas débat il faut choisir
normalement vous allez on voit c'est
thomas celui que vous le connaissez oui
oui non franchement je peux pas moi pas
m'embrasser moi je ne connais pas bien
ils ont été prudents va faire un jour à
tbb un tour atp tour à jour bon alors
par exemple le front c'est possible je
vais vous dire merci les chéris d'avoir
été avec nous parce qu'elle ne veut pas
vrai merci chers et merci en tout cas
c'était sympa d'être passée elle et elle
est très mignonne ta nouvelle meuf non
franchement je ne suis pas d'accord on
voit très bien
ne veut pas que ça se sache apparemment
un les mineurs coincés mais mignonne web
mais pas coincé signalé bien j'aime bien
mais qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout
4h15 là mais c'est vrai qu'à vendre il
faut lâcher les vins rosine qui est avec
nous pour être d'actu au patin alors
action vérité prenez ce que vous voulez
écoute petite joueuse vérité vérité
quel est ton plus grand fantasme
intéressant on on parle d'un fantasme ya
un cas particulier c'est qu'il ya un
truc comme ça ta soeur sur une fougère
la nature ouais c'est vrai la nature
alors si c'est un fantasme sexuel c'est
un truc je sais pas si c'est réalisable
mais j'aimerais bien faire l'amour en
apesanteur en apesanteur il faut appeler
calogero c'est le seul qui le fait le
seul qui le fait les autres en
apesanteur rappelé jeudi l'ancien
mannequin pour cela je vous ai perdus
sur les récits l'autre chrétien y croit
et c'est un gars qui était en apesanteur
en apesanteur
c'est vrai bon on va voir si c'est
possible son nouveau show jean michel a
l'air de dire que c'est possible un
monsieur aider airbus à toulouse qui
font des vols savez des vols
paraboliques et pendant quelques
secondes sortons en apesanteur afful
midi quelques secondes mais voilà jean
michel secondes michel dites moi si je
me trompe
non c'est j'avais mon titre j'ai
l'impression que vous qui fait bien
rosine pas autant elle en face de moi
donc je suis monté alors mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya quelques jeunes petits trucs
qu'aucun dans les yeux mais il ya des
meufs qui kiffe pas ça n'existe pas ça
marche ici pas trouvé encore et
heureusement c'est tout à votre honneur
thomert action vérité ce que tu veux du
moins ce que m'a dit on va on va voir et
thomert griffé tour est franchement
c'est tranquille pour toi embrasse la
fille la plus proche de toi
[Rires]
allez savoir
elle a de quoi purito actions merci
moujan mille mercis motion mais attend
et c'est toujours le même quel est ton
plus grand fantasme n'est pas bon la
refait elle est bonne quand une question
est bonne on peut leur poids russie
c'est ce que disait le record
d'actionnaires y séjournent à l'aria
très vite ces règles minutes c'est ce
que beaucoup de rêves minute quand même
dans ce jeudi c'est alors au plus il ya
son mec à côté ça c'est pas évident
j'étais obligée de mentir ou à vrai dire
le vrai nom s'est développée une vérité
si le maire soit oui et c'est toujours
plus simple de dire la vérité sonnera
mal à faire du bien j'avais comme disait
en entrevue avec les vérités sur la
ligue et au maire lui met la pression
mais dit mais de pression dit la vérité
alors fourni plusieurs mais un rat
comptable c'est l'amour à 3 1
non on était sûr peut dire ça mais parce
que dieu m'a regardé l'écran dans le
micro avec une meuf wake avec trois
filtres à troyes dans l'aube arrêté avec
un mec ou d'une meuf est ce que c'est
une deuxième question oui bah oui non
mais non plus avec une meuf domec avec
une autre marche bien ça simon c'est mon
papa il va pas qu'ils firent avec 7,9
avec l'autre mec non mesdames n'importe
quoi ou pas mais que je connais je
braille la personne ne va pas kiffer
temps mais c'est un délire mais se dit
que c'est pas vrai parce que je veux pas
que ton nom alors attendez je joue mais
très à l'aise j'ai déjà fait mille fois
très bien les fantasmes de ma meuf
donc tout va très bien alors j'ai des
infos qui tombent toutes les secondes
apparemment deborah la jeune fille qui
était là il ya un instant a changé
d'avis pour le smac nom qu'elle veut
bien se maquer quelqu'un sait pas ce
qu'elle va nous dire qui elle va venir
les rondes il ya des ralentissements
toutes les secondes y échanger des
devises est alors à ce qu'ils vont il
vaut mieux pas avoir de regrets non
c'est une idée quoi je pensais à
carreaux de quoi vous laisser marquer
car en fait c'est quoi mais vos parents
regardent ça pue écrit le couple non
merci et d'emballement faille et c'est
vous dire que vos parents vous voir
embrasser une meuf fin 2016 donc pas ses
vrais fin 2007 mais les parents sont
bonnes et on a alors sorti 6 à carreaux
est ce que vous seriez prête à embrasser
les bons ratios plus pas que je veuille
le faire mais bon mais dit il faut faire
non nous oriente manie naufrage on n'est
pas obligé du tout envie on vous a rien
dit c'est pas non plus vous avez la
délation vittel en vie quand vous avez
vraiment envie d'embrasser car on fait
pas une envie farouche et c'est un kiff
combien de minutes et me dire que
finalement non non non je reviendrai pas
on continue à faire
moi ce que je propose parce que après un
coach dont il faudra alors faire quel
est ton plus grand fantasme maintenant
je vais vous le dire voilà non mais
c'est nul à moi c'est pas nul en cinq
points nation suisse est comme si on
trouve ça nul on lui pose une question
répond quoi le fantasme la raison c'est
vrai il a raison je veux dire le
fantasme à l'oeuf en tan nou plus grands
fantasmes
bah je vais vous le dire c'est de lécher
les boules de bonus voilà pleinement
j'adore la télé mais loire le boulanger
et un moment de sincérité quoi dis-nous
vrai bon non mais un ça se respecte un
maxime vérité tu peux pas tuer
je crois que c'est impossible que
quelqu'un des patrons tasse alors ça
quelque part
et puis sur une cible on est entre nous
c'est pas comme si tu peux vous dire mon
plus grand fantasme ou soft et en plus
c'est vrai c'est que franchement cr site
c29 de meuf même annonce assez de toi
ces deux genres à gap
non mais à mater ok j'ai pas compris je
risquais mais mais mais vous feriez
ouvre par nos noms propres et noms du
genre mais têtue maintenance et il a dit
je vais donner ça c'est vraiment matters
alors 40 et sa bouille trône une
participerait évidemment il serait très
bon deborah quel est votre plus grand
fantasme ou la wii mais je suis un peu
comme ça j'en ai pas j'en ai pas trop
j'aime aussi beaucoup la télé ouais
ouais ok donc m'a excité et fier pour
aller marquer mais attention à la marche
c'est que sa démarche enfin ce que rafa
c'est les boules de mutisme à ses
démarches
oui mais après les passer au plan à
trois quand même donc et thouaré on en
chie du coin
avec arrow sur un plan sexuel à carreaux
avec quel animateur tu aimerais
éventuellement si tu devais avoir une
relation avec elle est une matière
ce gaz à la télé à l'ariana que je
trouve beau olivier minne exactement
ouais franchement dans danse avec les
stars il a un peu le voilà quoi régler
beaucoup de muscu la dhos a dit l'abe
diop il habite aux états unis ont poussé
d'année pour le noir là tu rentres une
tannée vraiment je ne risque pas vers 11
à l'eau froide et nommé jeudi la prend
des gens qui sont sur voilà c'est la
région française à posséder peine info
quoique non quoi l'impôt nominés jamais
là il a misé une cuisse et danse avec
les stars même dans cette histoire il
s'entraîne des états unis non
franchement prend quelqu'un de frontenex
france intra muros en intra muros maison
elle en quelqu'un qui est souvent là oui
bah oui cac et voilà nos ennemis
combelles bacchanales bas mais je te
disais que le taux bas les entrées et
ils arrivent ils arrivent tout à l'heure
puisque je fais le morning avec la cisr
est ce que ça te dirait de ce mac et
camille combal vers 6 heures je peux
être là et 6 heures c'est vrai car
rendez compte ou pas quoique bien ok en
fait juste thomas i kissed et nana nommé
tôt pour moi j'aurais aimé qu'on balaie
en train de dire que l me pas trop mal
paillade à mi-combat de travail travail
travail travail qu'ils ont fait était
souvent lesquels métaux miley peau bien
j'ai dit que je trouvais beau garçon
okami est ce que tu as envie de
l'embrasser
oui oui et du non après les personnes
marais pétoires et toi ouais ouais je
vais te dire que tu mets toi je vais
tenir ces genres je touche aux régies
touche pas et toi ta question tu me
demandes qui le trouve beau nom mais je
t'ai demandé comme c'est bizarre et seek
amy veut t'embrasser vers 6 heures avant
qu'on prenne landu l'antenne pour la
radio ce que tu ferais à voir ouais à
voir donc ouais voilà bon oui thomas 0
je vais dire la vérité à mes thomas
meiway ramène la ramène à la maison et
du lui quand même bien parce que là
frère tu es mort de che mort mais
personne pour te massa 1 enfin il
l'aurait ramenée chez elle fait un
pardon mais on couche ensemble
oui ou non peut-être faut voir alors je
sais pas oui j'ai envie mais c'est pas
une envie folle folle ne sais pas dit
elle à la cagnotte
oui bah oui mais voilà beaucoup de
succès non avant vaut mieux - mignonne
mais voilà quel âge tu as quel âge 25
ans tu avoueras qu'on te pose rarement
la question qui veut tu embrasses et
maintenant tout de suite ça va et au et
je vais te dire on est dans un monde
aujourd'hui
ou si tu embrasses pas aujourd'hui tu as
peu de chance d'embrasser demain ben oui
parce qu'après tout c'est beau ce qu on
va se quitter
c'est beau j'aimerais tous voilà avant
qu'on se quitte parce que je dois
préparer aussi la radio avec camille pas
ce que l'avenir me le chercher vers 5h30
voilà donc par là je réponds tout ce
qu'on termine sur un mot de la fin le
mot qui vous vient à l'esprit
sur cette soirée sur la vie tous les
jours sur ces 35 heures sur en fait sur
cette société qui nous entoure
jean michel gros si tu vas trouver autre
chose
attention alors vous débarrasser les
bras bravo alors moi je dirais que déjà
je suis pas ravi d'être là n'a fait
bravo pour les 35 heures je vais suivre
les prochaines heures
il en reste encore beaucoup et
elle est super mais on s'expose et
thomas benyamine on connaît on va sur
thomas le mot de la soirée c'est bien
sûr voilà j'étais venu pour pécho je
repars une main devant une main derrière
et deborah dommage parce que je pourrais
bien vu desquelles être très très
mignonne ouais ça fait longtemps que tu
m'as pas ramené une baffe au séminaire
c'est le dire - période je ne vais
attendre à la fin
oui qu'ils pensent et vivent 35 heures
thomert thomert écoute moi j'ai dû mater
un petit peu les primaires et je me suis
beaucoup plus amusé on te regarde toi
matin d'avenches et c'est vrai cette
norme aurait été quand même inquiétant
que ce soit le contraire mais je me suis
pris par le rire des roues un moment il
a retiré mike les temps c'était bien ou
pas le sondage père parce qu'on n'a pas
pu les voir
c'était non vous l'avez rendre en
dessous c'est un peu méchant et c'était
bien qu'ils débattent franchement rosine
notre nature elle est belle plante elle
aime la vie sociale m le boomerang et
ben gratitude écoute parce que je trouve
qu'on a passé un super moment j'ai passé
une super soirée avec vous et je suis
plein de gratitude d'être là et puis
d'avoir partagé ce moment avec vous tous
penser à l'après zambiens merci les
honfleurais matthieu delormeau
oui c'est vrai moi j'ai pas dit mon
dernier mot ah oui car audi n'a alors
moi je dirais triste pourquoi mais parce
que je trouve qu'il est trop tôt pour se
quitter bon ça coco
4h27 je sais pas moi on m'a dit 6h 5h
parce que là là en fait je vous explique
aubenas genre tu veux dormir je me
repose un peu avec les téléspecteurs il
reste avec moi écouter les restaurants
avec moi je vais dormir avec eux parfois
je leur dirai les choses
si j'ai envie de besoin de vous confier
je me confierait à eux si voilà je dirai
les choses que j'ai envie de jouer envie
d'en parler j'ai envie 2 savez je vous
dire à cette france c'est aussi ma
france monsieur mathieu et bien moi je
dirais franchise je vous conseille
beaucoup de choses sur ces canapés ce
soir là s'arrête tous fait beaucoup de
bien j'aime mais c'est vrai oui je me
demande si on va pas faire ça peut
l'être une fois par mois avril et koné
avec toute l'équipe de touche pas à mon
pote oui pour vraiment se remettre les
choses à plat et droz se dire
chose faire des confessions non mais
sans déconner c'est le train deviendrai
4 puis j'en vois un concept jamais
carrément donc voilà sans déconner avec
tout le monde qui est chaud oui moi papa
je t'aime
et bien c'est fait et ben seignal ça
s'est fait à bord du m je crois que
c'est bon dumercy deborah la vérité
merci à vous je veux remercier mon ami
thomert déjeuner ou chèque vous pourrez
savoir est-ce que de temps en temps
est-ce que je peux passer de temps en
temps juste pour passer un peu de temps
avec toi sur la mission et c'est juste
pour kiffer mais mais mais coûte
l'émission est toujours ouverte
malheureux et je suis là encore pour
quelques temps mais quand je suis là si
tu rends tu kiffes tu viens n'en peut
plus tout le monde aime bien non mais
c'est vrai tout le monde tout le monde
le typhon melor rejoindre lui
demanderons de nous il ya des gars je
vais te dire qu'est ce que je suis en
plus ils demandent pas de pige d'un
mondial tu viens tu es chez toi
non moi je veux vraiment je prends je
prends garçons argent sert garçons kif
je te tue moi j'en profite parce que on
se voit pas beaucoup non mais c'est vrai
vraiment et quand on est content de te
voir c'est vrai et je prends énormément
de plaisir à te regarder at-elle
vraiment je te fais un gros bisou est-ce
que je donne procès
merci mon chéri d'amour tu viens
continue et elle ta seule faut que tu
viens de la voir aussi chez camille
combal et chérie mois et attend cyril
juste un truc en est vrai de vrai parce
que je pense que vraiment ça intéresse
les gens qui nous regardent et ce côté
là est ce que tu es fatigué genre est ce
que tu pourrais tout le temps envie de
dormir
est ce que tu peux tenir pas de ouf mais
je vais me reposer un peu parce que
parce que tu penses à assurer nos
journées devant des bras de mer c'est
surtout pour l'avoir reposé la voie à
une heure moi parce que demain on aura
combien nous raconte un temps d'antenne
à partir de là il nous reste quand même
temps il est 4h30 à la calculer cela
fait quatorze heures trente
il nous reste quand même fait du
directeur du réseau il nourrit un rêve
un jour est 21h quand même on n'a même
pas fait la boîte ouais on est dans la
merde il faut du du miel de manuka c'est
ce qui ma cicatrice mtv de ta gorge du
miel de manuka dignac manuka un accord
et c'est pour ça que ça va bien merci
alors elle est chéri bon et on a le
choix demain que de manier une grosse
journée
on va on va se régaler voilà mes chéris
vous allez rentrer dormir
absolument vous vous attendiez avec qui
lui a non mais là tout seul là de la
jeune voisine
j'ouvre ma journée vous devez ensemble
importance accrue ce témoin le petit
couple a balayé mon cerveau il est parti
on va jouer la c1 ton nom mais on finit
la soirée chez vous tout simplement l
autre les gens vont l'aimer calmos gérer
comme quoi on peut très bien faire un
truc sandra que la toxine j'étais dire
non mais alors pas du tout vous voulez
on veut pas entendre parler de ça
vraiment ils doivent venir ou sur genlis
et pengfei fans avec rosine d'accord
c'est sur le dossier quoiqu'il
jean-michel oui oui oui oui oui ça va
bien merci merci les amoureux merci les
amoureux midam en l'amour
allez on se retrouve dans un instant
avec moi je serai tout seul les cherry
on se dit tout de suite mais chérie je
vous lâche pas de façon on reste à
l'antenne a tout de suite
[Musique]